this was the star of the 1967
International Motor Show in Frankfurt
the NSU ro AV MSU was a car maker with a
long history in Germany and with the Rho
80 it presented both an innovative
design and an entirely new technology
the design followed the technology the
pioneering wedge shape with a compressed
front was made possible by the
relatively small rotary piston engine
under the hood our mean boda was
involved in the development of the NSU
ro ATS Bunko engine the one thing which
explains that the volkl engines mass is
balanced a great advantage over the
reciprocating piston engine which is
harder to balance the vibration is
always carried over to the vehicle and a
rotary engine by contrast there's hardly
any vibration inside the car the car
just takes off with the engine purring
like an electric motor
another benefit was the power density or
the performance potential the
reciprocating piston engines of the time
were somewhat weaker so the rotary
engine offered some advantages there to
lie storage pits efficient light stone
to Israel oh and the swamp so the
argument that even hotter
NSU mounted its first 115 horsepower to
rotor funcle' engines in the row ad
even more than 47 years later the
innovative aerodynamic form looks
amazingly modern for a vintage car it
looks at least 20 years younger half a
lifetime in the history of automotive
design from the late 1940s to the mid
1960s NSU focused on smaller models the
row ad was only the car makers first
experiment with a larger car and it was
the world's first series produced sedan
with a rotary engine the engineers who
worked on it still wax sentimental
I mean bouta says they were surprised at
first they couldn't believe it all of a
sudden here was a top-of-the-range model
with such a sleek design the body was
meant to be tailored to the engine which
was compact and low writing and it
didn't even have conventional Pistons
the neatly inclined Paulding 20 Fleeman
motor or the skiing thermal standoff
kind who called me 9
the specifications weren't decent for
the time it was the price tag that
scared off potential buyers in 1967 the
row cost more than 14,000 Deutsche marks
NSU emphasized its high quality interior
the interior itself was an innovative
pioneering but workmanship and comfort
were first-rate the power steering was
connected to a three-spoked wheel with
impact absorber the trunk offered nearly
500 80 litres of space with room for
expansion
well-formed seats and a long-wheelbase
made for a comfortable ride
unfortunately the row eighty guzzled
about 15 liters of fuel per hundred
kilometers a fatal flaw when the first
oil crisis hit it was and remained a car
for individual lists but the customer
base just wasn't large enough to keep
the row ad going over the long run row
80 remained in production for 10 years
until 1977 producing close to thirty
seven thousand five hundred units but
the problems with the rotary engine
weren't solved until the very end then
it turned out to be a very sturdy engine
but it was too late to rescue the car's
reputation
you